,
arrogant bullying cowards,
that's a focus of ties angle.
Now in 2009 when the tea party
took off, so many Americans were
energized and that was the
opposition to Obamacare.
The one good thing about the
awful terrible pandemic is that
the parents have the time to
burrow into their children's
schooling.
And many were horrified about
what they saw.
And it wasn't so awful after
all.
>> It will tear this country
apart.
>> It's is teaching kids how to
hate each other.
>> I want credible race theory,
and talk to my kids in school
does not mean I'm a racist.
>> Apparently school boards
across America thought they
could radically revamp course
offerings from American history
to literature and no one would
notice.
Now parents and citizens alike
see how activists promoting a
deeply anti-American agenda have
wormed their way into almost
every facet of the educational
experience.
While parents should be upset
about this, and their concerns
are not political.
Parents are saying, and that's
equity and inclusion amp police
brutality, at where the saying
that in school they put more
focus on George Floyd than
George Washington.
Parents should be demanding
answers because schools have
become a minefield for Democrats
of course.
And they took the side of school
boards against the parents.
After the school Board
Association and pleaded for
relief claiming its members were
under siege, the Department of
Justice snapped into action.
I've never seen anything like
it.
In their own memo they warned of
a disturbing spike in the
harassment, intimidation and
threats of violence against
school administrators and
promised to take action if
necessary.
It sent a chilling message to
moms and dads, pretty much
anyone from coast-to-coast.
And a firestorm then erupted and
the school board pulled back and
saw they had created a bit of a
ruckus.
So they apologized for the
description of violent harassing
menaces.
And presumably you wrote the
memo because of the letter.
The letter is disavowed now and
you keep your memo going anyway.
>> Senator, I have the letter
from an SBA that you're
referring to end it apologizes
for language in the letter but
it continues its concern about
the safety of school officials
and school staff.
>> Laura: Okay.
But the point wasn't to
intimidate parents, why does the
DOJ invoke a national security
components?
>> You are going to credit a
task force that includes a
national security division.
What does the national security
division have to do with parents
at school boards?
>> This is not again about
parents at school boards, it's
about threats of violence.
>> Again this begs the question,
why would the suddenly be a new
federal matter?
Any threats or violence are
already prosecutable under state
law as well as federal law in
some cases so why the need for a
deal Jake task force?
>> How is that the Department of
Justice was able to move so
rapidly on a single letter from
a special interest group that
has now repudiated that letter,
said it regret sending the
letter and apologizes to its
members for sending the letter?
>> Answer is when we get reports
of violence and threats of
violence we need to act swiftly.
>> You didn't investigate the
incidences cited in the letter.
Did you?
>> I took the statement by the
National Association, when they
said they were facing violence
and threats of violence and when
we saw in the news media
reports.
>> But you didn't invest the
incidents in the letter, did
you?
>> This is an assessment step
and it comes before the
investigations.
Speed when it come on.
We all know what happened,
presumably the White House let
it be known that they needed
this whole school controversy to
quiet down and for parents to
pipe down, dangling the
possibility of FBI action gets
parents, just attending school
board meetings would be one way
to get that done, or so they
thought.
This was all coordinated and it
blew up spectacularly.
>> Are you aware of
conversations between you are
Department of Justice officials,
White House officials and
members of the school Board
Association all cooperating
together?
>> I'm sure there were
conversations with the
White House, I have no idea
whether there were conversations
with the school Board
Association.
There is nothing wrong with
there being those conversations
and is nothing annual about the
organization to suggest it was
in any way partisan.
>> Laura: All those
conservatives on school boards
and associations.
Of course it's not partisan,
it's all just a coincidence that
school boards are overwhelmingly
liberal.
And what about this underlying
evidence?
Is there really a growing
national threat posed against
the school boards?
Committee chair Dick Durbin was
reaching for anything.
>> Those who argue at school
board meetings across America
are not more dangerous or more
violent than the past.
I went on I just typed in this
morning, school board violence
on one of the search engines,
page after pages coming up.
>> Laura: 24 years in the
Senate ladies and gentlemen, and
he is just and entering terms
into search engines and
proclaiming it so.
Another argument for term
limits.
This is all too much.
If Glenn Youngkin wins the
Virginia gubernatorial race, it
will be because he focuses so
much on the travesty unfolding
on the education issue in
Loudoun County.
Rape and school bathrooms and
coverups and the parents who
dared to ask questions even the
family of the victims.
Meanwhile Democratic candidate
Terry McAuliffe is flailing.
>> I'm sick of them talking
about these issues of critical
race theory, we do not teach
critical race theory here in
Virginia.
It has never been taught.
>> This is what MS-13, the
Republicans used for
Governor Northam.
They tried to find a divisive
tactic.
>> Laura: That's pathetic.
McAuliffe is to bought off by
the teachers unions to see that
this goes way beyond Glenn
Youngkin.
This is about parents
discovering in many cases for
the first time the truth about a
growing socialist monopoly in
education.
The angle worn, warned you about
this.
Black Lives Matter Black Lives
Matter zealots have influenced
and school districts like
Fairfax County and their goal is
to turn your kids into hard-core
activists by remaking education
from top to bottom.
>> I would watch hours of the
school board meetings and it's
horrifying what we are seeing.
It's a big business.
It's pedagogue's and cultural
Marxism, implicit bias training,
the colonizing syllabi and this
extremism is like a cult.
>> Laura: And now that many of
us are on to them, progressive
school boards and districts
across America are freaking out.
Do they change the reticle cores
or do they just try to
discourage parental involvement
on all these hot button issues.
The Mankato, Minnesota, school
board chores, chose the latter.
>> It's a business meeting of
the school board, not a meeting
that belongs to the public.
Each speaker is asked to state
his or her name for the record
and failure to do so will result
in the individual not being
allowed to speak.
Participants are prohibited from
calling out or addressing any
individual school board or
school district staff member.
>> Laura: Do you understand
what she said?
If a parents concern is not on
her agenda, I guess the
controversy or concern didn't
happen, it's like magic and it
just goes away.
It seems like there's another
school board that needs be
replaced.
Taxpaying parents, and any
politician stands in the way of
this legitimate exercise of
parental rights and any
bureaucrat who uses procedural
gimmicks to insulate himself
from criticism should be tossed
from office as soon as possible.
This spells political defeat and
countless Democrats who b